so last year we showed you how to roast
a turkey hole this year we're taking a
little bit of a different approach and
showing you how to roast the turkey in
its parts
it's going to give you a better result
it's going to be way faster trust me
breaking down your turkey ahead of time
is the ultimate thanksgiving hack
[Music]
even though we're going to be breaking
it down to its pieces we still want to
be cognizant of how big our bird is so
typically they say about a pound per
person
the fda no longer recommends washing
your bird because it can spread and
contaminate the rest of your kitchen so
we're just going to take it out of the
packaging pat it down with paper towels
and get moving my first time breaking on
a bird a lot of this is just making
these exploratory cuts so you can see
what you're doing so just be slow take
your time shouldn't be a ton of cutting
through bone
we're gonna take out the neck and the
innards we're also gonna super quickly
cut off the wingtips those would just
char roasting with the rest of the stuff
so we're gonna use those for our stock
and we're gonna turn our bird over first
thing we wanna do is release the oysters
and the oysters are this really great
chunk of meat on the back of the bird
and they are attached to the thighs here
are wings those are our oysters and our
legs and thighs
so we're going to do a cut down the
backbone just to release the skin and
make a little cross you can kind of feel
them right here and just cut above them
you're just going to use the tip of your
knife and kind of scrape around and
release that oyster it's kind of like a
half circle if you will and if you leave
some meat on the bone that's totally
fine you just want to get as much as you
can and once you get it released to this
point you're going to turn the turkey
over
now we're going to release the legs
here are our wings up here and our
breast first off you're just going to
release the skin with your knife just
one smooth motion and that's just so
that we can see what we're doing now so
you're going to use your fingers being
careful always keep your fingers away
from your knife we're going to first
start by releasing some of the meat from
the bottom of the carcass right where my
hand is at this point we're just going
to pop out the joint so it's kind of
crazy you kind of like put your hand
underneath the thigh with your other
hand move the rest of the carcass off to
one side use your fingers to pop the
joint out
you'll feel some pressure and then all
of a sudden it'll pop once we release
the thighs and the legs we're just going
to leave them here they're just acting
as a stabilizer and we're going to move
up to the breast and remove that so with
the breastbone we're going to cut down
the middle again a little exploratory
cut then you can use your fingertips to
feel where the edge of the breastbone is
and just do nice long smooth cuts
i like to kind of release the smaller
thinner part of the breast and kind of
fold it up as i go and fold it to the
side so i can really see where i'm going
and scrape down the breastbone as best i
can to release all the meat
just work slow and steady your main goal
is to get as much meat off as you can
you can see there's some tendons up here
near the shoulder and we're just looking
for that shoulder joint we're going to
use the tip of my knife and scrape off
any meat so that i can see a little bit
better cut through any tendons and then
the nice thing about the shoulder joint
is it's quite large once you get to that
point you can kind of see right where it
is and use the tip of your knife to
expose it if you're hitting the right
place it shouldn't be hard on your knife
now we have our breast and our wing
removed um we're going to put that off
to the side so we can get the next
breast off so do the same thing we're
going to go on the other side of the
breastbone and release the rest of the
breast as we go
and voila
so we started removing the legs and the
thighs but now we're going to finish
that process
i'm just going to kind of pull the
carcass away from the thigh and just
start releasing the tendons and the skin
and the meat away from the carcass
the one thing that we want to be aware
of here is we want to take that oyster
with us
here's the thigh here's the leg and then
the oyster is in that top right
same to deal with the other ones so kind
of pull the carcass away release the
meat and skin where you can taking that
oyster with you
and we're off
so i'm going to use the carcass now
i'm going to take the tips with me as
well and the turkey neck and we're going
to roast those off with some vegetables
and make a really good stock
do not throw this stuff away please make
the stock it's going to make your gravy
taste insane
i'm just gonna clean down a little bit
i'm gonna fresh board clean off my knife
get some fresh gloves always working
with a clean environment and always
being really organized so we got these
big regions off the bird but now we're
gonna break these off into their grocery
pieces if you will so we have the thigh
and the leg we want to separate those
two so the easiest way is to turn them
over because you don't have that skin
inhibiting where you can see you have
this fat line in between and it's kind
of this weird natural line that's
telling you where to cut which is great
so we're going to cut right along that
fat line to expose the skin again we're
always looking for the joint you can
find the joint and you can use the
little tip of your knife to kind of
separate a little bit and then just cut
right through it again if this is really
hard then you're probably in the wrong
place so just kind of move your knife
around a few times until you get a
really nice smooth cut all right so here
is our breasts and our wing the nice
thing about this too is that now you
know where all the bones are so it's
going to make it much easier when you're
carving later if you've ever carved a
whole bird and you're just guessing your
way through it this is going to make it
so much easier later on when you're
portioning out the different pieces
because of the way that we cut off the
breast it's basically boneless so all we
really need to do is cut off the
shoulder bit so don't overthink this you
can cut a good amount of the breast bead
off and have it go with the wing because
it's like a little bit of an extra treat
for whoever gets the wing part as well
as it just makes your life easier one
thing that we want to be aware of too is
that all the pieces are relatively close
in size
we'll follow that up with the other
breast and the other thigh
[Music]
and then we are good to go so we're
going to clean down real quickly again i
just want to make sure that i'm
being as clean as possible
really hot soapy water get all the bits
really do a good job and then follow up
with a spray sanitizer or antibacterial
spray
so into our brine so o'brien really just
consists of salt and sugar i'm not a big
believer in a wet brine dry brine for
life salt and sugar are desiccants and
they're going to draw out moisture but
once they draw out that moisture it then
reseeps back into the meat so you get a
really flavorful really juicy meat when
it's all said and done so i'm going to
start with salt
brown sugar so it's going to give us a
little bit of a molassy flavor
molasses i was corrected molasses flavor
oh fine it gives us a little molasses
flavor and then i'm going to use some
cracked black pepper look at this this
is freshly cracked nice big chunks not
only that like a weird powder stuff that
comes pre-done so much more aromatic and
flavorful i'm going to use a little bit
of garlic granule so this is kind of in
between a powder and the dried like
chips that you can get the nice thing
about the garlic granules is that they
have a ton of flavor but they
incorporate really really well so stir
those all together something about a
spice mix isn't it pretty put that off
to the side and we're going to bring
back our turkey the cool thing about
breaking the turkey down in its pieces
is that we're really able to season all
sides of the meat which is another great
reason to be breaking your meat down
ahead of time so some birds will have a
few feathers left in don't freak out
just pull them out if you have tweezers
that can be helpful but they should be
pretty big so if you don't get all of
them it's fine they'll kind of burn off
when roasting but there's any huge ones
you want to get those out and then we're
going to season all sides of the bird
just make sure i'm kind of patting it
down getting all sides and all the skin
uh really well coated in the brine we're
doing this a day ahead so we are going
to actually leave these in the fridge
uncovered overnight that's going to
really draw the moisture out of the skin
so we're going to have super super
crispy great skin when it's all said and
done
for making the stock because we want to
do the gravy we want to mimic those
great roasty toasty dripping bits that
you would get from roasting your turkey
so i'm going to throw the turkey carcass
the wingtips and the neck on a baking
sheet i'm going to put on celery onions
i'm going to quarter those leave the
skin on and then also some carrots as
well
lightly season everything because all
these flavors will be concentrated i
don't want to over salt this and a
little bit of oil again for lubrication
throw that in a super hot oven for about
30 minutes or so just to get a little
bit of that my yard reaction from all
the meat as well as caramelize the sugar
in the vegetables and then i'm going to
take everything that was on this tray
and put it into a big pot cover it with
water so i'm gonna pour off all the
extra fat and i'm gonna put some water
on this hot baking tray and scrape all
of those brown bits look at all of the
flavor that's on here that's all that
onion sugar and the drippings from the
carcass basically like deglazing the
baking tray
[Music]
so i have the fat in one and the liquids
in the other
these drippings will be saved for the
gravy
[Music]
so with the carcass i'm gonna cover this
up with water all the way and then
simmer this guy for about two and a half
three hours or so and that's going to
give you the most delicious stock you've
ever tasted is going to be amazing
so when you're making a gravy the first
step is making a roux and a roux is
equal parts flour and fat so we're going
to use our fat drippings from roasting
the carcass and then we're going to add
equal parts flour and we're going to
just toast this off for a little bit so
we want to cook the flour a little bit
before we add too much liquid
and that's to do two things one it's
going to help beat out any lumps and two
it's going to help cook out the flour
flavor and we're going to gradually add
liquid to this because if you add too
much liquid at once it's going to be
really really hard to beat out those
lumps just the best way to ensure that
you're going to have a really smooth
gravy in the end so i'm gonna take my
time here adding a little bit of liquid
as we go do have to babysit it quite a
bit and again we're gonna use all of the
drippings from when we were deglazing
the pan earlier so i'm gonna use a
strainer just to be extra safe because
there were you know some of the onion
and other skin and stuff remaining on
the pan from the drippings add the rest
of that in all the fat and all of the
drippings are incorporated but it's
still pretty thick flour will start to
thicken once it gets to a boil that's
why you want to keep the heat pretty
high because if you're on too low of a
heat all this time you'll be afraid to
add too much liquid because it won't
thicken up now we're going to use the
stock that we made to finish off this
gravy and thin it out a little bit you
could also use water which is going to
really not be a ton of flavor you could
do store bought if you've decided not to
make the stock but trust me the stock
that we made earlier is going to make a
big big difference so once you get to a
good place and you feel like it's a good
thinness while we used a little bit of
salt just to kind of enhance the flavor
of the meat and the vegetables before we
haven't seasoned it at all so you want
to make sure that you taste it and
you're going to have to add a
significant amount of seasoning right
now because again we haven't really
added much seasoning up until this point
and again just keep tasting and
seasoning until it's just right all
right so i'm happy with this we're gonna
put it off to the side to cool and then
that's done so all you need to do on the
day of is just reheat that in a pan and
it's done
we're going to preheat our oven to 425
just go ahead and put a little bit of
oil on it and that will help with even
browning and we're going to leave it in
there for about 30 minutes that's going
to get us instant heat instant color and
really dry out that skin right away and
then once it's been in for about 30
minutes we're going to lower it down to
400 switch the positions of the pans and
rotate them as well just if you have any
hot spots in your oven this will just
help with that and then continue
roasting until the instant read
thermometer inserted into the thickest
part of the breast registers 160. so
this is about like 30 minutes and for
the thighs we want to take it out around
170. so if any pieces are already done
and others need a little bit more time
you can just pull those out ahead of
time so they don't ever cook
once our turkey's done take it out of
the oven cover it with foil let it sit
for about five to ten minutes because
these are smaller pieces they don't need
to rest as long as the whole birds
they'll cool down a lot faster
and then we'll carve them
so now that our meat has cooled a little
bit it's a little bit easier to handle
we're gonna carve it for the table the
thigh again it's easier to see on the
other side you can see where that bone
is and we're going to cut off the meat
in large chunks again just cutting off
the bone as best you can cut off the top
like all that meat around the bone it's
the less pretty stuff but it's still
delicious so we're going to put that in
the bottom of the platter and the way
that i'm cutting this is i'm making sure
that every bite has a little bit of skin
next up we're gonna separate the wing
and the easiest way to do this is just
put it on its side cut down the middle
and then you can even just kind of like
tear it apart you can see you expose
that joint cut through it and good to go
and then all of that meat that we put on
there all that white meat from the
breast is on there as well so that's a
good piece the leg it's perfect as it's
just put it on the platter and then
another thigh same deal how juicy it is
it's amazing
and for the breast again i'm going to
cut down
the skin on a diagonal and making sure
that everyone's getting a little bit of
skin because you have done all these
pieces you can take your time making all
these cuts really nice and making your
platter really great because you haven't
had to completely carve out an entire
bird so it should be a lot easier and
you have a little bit more time for that
presentation so i like to put the
dark meat on the side again all of those
smaller cuts that were a little bit
uglier go on the bottom and then you
just lay those nice breast pieces on top
the really impressive cuts
and then i like to just spruce it up
with a little bit of green
this is how it would come to the table
normally people don't even know that you
didn't cook it on the carcass if you
want to tell people that you did that's
fine but i think we should evangelize
this method we made gravy from it we
made stock from the whole thing so we
learned how to break down a bird as well
it's so much cheaper to be buying whole
chickens whole turkeys hold ducks you
name it and now that you know how to
break it down it's the same method for
all birds i just can't understand why
you wouldn't do it this way honestly
going forward this is the only way i'm
doing my turkey from now on sometimes
traditions just need to be upgraded you
know and like updated enjoy have a great
holiday season guys
oh yes
[Music]
you